* Klopfen *
Jawohl?
Sali.
- Guten Morgen.
Ihr seid für mich zuständig?
- Ja. Chris.
Patrick. Freut mich auch.
- Patrick, freut mich auch.
Super Sache, dass du hier bist.
- Ich freue mich. Was habt ihr vor?
Ja, wie es das Logo schon sagt:
Du bist bei der Feuerwehr.
Und jetzt gibt es
ganz spontan einen Crashkurs dazu,
was ein Feuerwehrmann so macht.
"Vorsicht Schacht". Jawohl.
Der ist angeschrieben. In
deinem Zimmer ist eine grosse Türe.
Dort befindet sich
auch ein Sprungschacht.
Der Unterschied zwischen dieser Türe
und der herkömmlichen ist,
dass die Türklinke
gegen oben öffnet.
Damit du, wenn du sie nachts
zufälligerweise berührst,
nicht runterfällst.
Dahinter ist diese Stange.
Ja, Scheibenkleister.
- Schau mal runter.
Sprungschacht ...
Hast du das schon mal gemacht?
- Nein! Nein.
Im Turnen oder so?
- Doch, raufgeklettert.
Wer von euch macht's vor?
Oder muss ich mich dranhängen?
Jetzt Achtung! Chris.
Das Wichtigste ist,
sie mal in der Hand zu halten.
Dann bist du sicher,
dass du sie festhältst,
und du schepperst
nicht daneben vorbei.
Dann hältst du dich
mit beiden Händen fest,
mit den Beinen umschlingst du sie.
Du rutschst automatisch
ein bisschen,
dann kannst du entweder mit
beiden Händen etwas bremsen.
* Quietschen *
Ich habe jetzt schon
schweissnasse Hände.
Also, und jetzt ...
Wie war das?
- (Patrick) Umschlingen.
(Chris) Mit dem ringsum.
Mit dem anderen da. Perfekt.
Das geht ... Und abwärts.
- Jetzt abwärts.
Abwärts geht's.
- Langsam. Jawohl.
Das war die kurze Übungsstange?
- Genau, wir fangen immer ...
Und die in meinem Zimmer?
Das wäre eine lange.
Wie die zweite und dritte.
Das sind jeweils zwei Stockwerke.
Das ist maximal erlaubt.
Alles darüber
wäre nicht mehr Suva-konform.
(Patrick) Dann zeigen wir dir
deine Brandschutzbekleidung.
Das wäre deine Ausrüstung.
Mit Brandschutzhelm,
Brandschutzjacke
und Hose mit Stiefeln.
Ich würde sagen:
Probier es einfach mal aus!
In 60 Sek. müsst ihr das schaffen.
- Richtig, ja.
Hosenträger an.
Ja, da ist noch ein bisschen Platz.
Gut.
Tipptopp.
- Tipptopp.
Wie ein Marsmensch. Mondlandung.
(In Vollmontur
muss ich zum Eignungstest.)
(Einen Morgen lang
tappte ich im Dunkeln,
aber nun finde ich raus, was es
mit dem Blindenstock auf sich hat.)
Ein Blindenstock
ist ein gutes Hilfsmittel,
wenn wir in einem grossen Raum
oder in einem Gang sind.
Damit kann man
eine grosse Bodenfläche absuchen.
Aha, okay. Ja.
(Patrick simuliert mit mir
einen Brandeinsatz.)
Da wir hier drin keinen Rauch haben,
klebe ich dir Folie auf.
Das macht, dass du ...
Oh!
* Sie lacht. *
... ein wenig das Feeling
von Rauch bekommst.
Du gehst einfach voraus
und suchst mit dem Blindenstock ab.
So erhältst du
ein bisschen ein Gefühl dafür,
wie gross der Raum
oder der Gang ist.
(Mit der Folie über der Brille
sehe ich praktisch nichts.)
Man hat keine Vorstellung vom Raum,
in dem man sich bewegt.
So ist es, wenn es brennt?
Ja, es geht immer noch weiter.
(Irgendwo hier
hat Patrick eine Puppe versteckt.)
Wand. Irgendetwas.
* Mona lacht. *
Ich habe einen Kameramann gefunden.
- Den suchen wir nicht.
Dann wieder rechtsrum.
Was liegt da noch?
- Wonach fühlt es sich an?
Das ist ein Mensch.
Da liegt einer, ja.
- Da haben wir ein Bein.
Dann versuchen wir,
ihn rückwärts rauszunehmen.
Okay.
So.
Meine Güte! Ich bin jetzt schon
ziemlich erledigt.
Man kommt ins Schwitzen,
obwohl man nicht viel macht.
Ja, wirklich.
- So ist die Thematik.
Schlussendlich
muss man sagen können,
dass man 100 % abgesucht hat.
Die Verantwortung, die ihr tragt,
ist massiv.
Stell dir vor: Du bist in einem
Gebäude, irgendwo liegt ein Kind
und du hast es nicht gesehen.
Richtig.
Das gilt es möglichst zu verhindern.
Dann gehen wir hier weiter.
(Und jetzt gilt es richtig ernst.)
Alles in Ordnung mit der Maske?
- Ja.
Ab hier geht es runter.
(Jeder Bewerber muss es
durch diesen Käfig schaffen.)
(Wer in Panik gerät oder seine Kol-
legen im Stich lässt, fällt durch.)
Da wird es auch schon etwas warm.
(Heiss, eng, keine Sicht, ich kämpfe
mit der Maske, die zu gross ist,
und aus der die Luft
nur so hinauspfeift.)
* Vibrierende Bassklänge *
* Laute Atemgeräusche *
Boah!
Ach, Scheisse! Ehrlich!
Hier brauchen wir Teamwork.
Ja, meine Güte!
Geht es für dich?
- Ja.
Zurück.
(Nach 10 Min. habe ich den Ausgang
aus dem Labyrinth gefunden.)
(Ich pfeife aus dem letzten Loch.)
* Pfeifton *
Habe ich keine Luft mehr?
Was du jetzt hörst,
ist die Restwarneinrichtung.
Die sagt,
dass du jetzt noch
bei ca. 50 bar bist.
Okay.
50 bar Luft, d.h., du hast nur noch
ein paar Minütchen Zeit, um ...
Um mich selber zu retten.
... aus dieser feindlichen Umgebung
rauszukommen.
(Den Eignungstest
habe ich bestanden.)
(Mit dieser Maske
zu einem echten Einsatz,
das muss von mir aus nicht sein
in den nächsten 24 Std.)
(Wenn kein Einsatz läuft,
kümmern sich die Feuerwehrmänner
um den Unterhalt oder gönnen sich
auch mal einen Kaffee.)
(Immer mit einem Ohr
beim Lautsprecher.)
(Lautsprecher) Achtung!
Technische Hilfeleistung klein,
verletzter Storch in ...
(unverständlich)
Ausrücken.
(Die Feuerwehr
macht auch Tierrettungen.)
(Ein verletzter Storch
wurde in einem Park gemeldet.)
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Störche, Schwäne oder allgemein
Tiere, die davonfliegen können ...
Ja, eben.
- Da machst du dich oft zum Affen.
Du meinst, für uns
könnte das noch lustig werden?
* Dynamische Klänge *
(Einer dieser Störche
soll verletzt sein,
hat ein Parkbesucher gemeldet.)
(Chris will ihn einfangen
und ihn zum Tierarzt bringen.)
Ah, schau, die können noch fliegen.
(Nachäffend) "Der kann nicht
fliegen. Der kann nicht fliegen."
So viel zum Thema:
Sie können nicht fliegen.
Es kann auch einfach jemand sein,
der ...
Der dachte, es sei so.
Ja, der dachte, es sei so.
Aber es ist nichts.
Wenn du ihn anschaust -
er steht halt einfach.
Wie ein Storch
halt wahrscheinlich dasteht.
Aber das sehen die Menschen
manchmal anders.
Wie ich gesagt habe: Wir machen uns
oft zum Affen bei solchen Sachen.
"Was macht ihr hier eigentlich?"
"Wir wissen es selber nicht genau."
Jemand sagt, er sei verletzt.
Wir müssen schauen gehen.
Dann gehst du schauen und ...
- Ist nichts.
Dann fliegen sie davon wie jetzt.
Die sehen eigentlich gesund aus.
Was macht ihr sonst
für Tierrettungen? Was gehört dazu?
Die Katze auf dem Baum.
Das ist der Klassiker.
Da musst du echt jeweils rauf?
Ja, mit einer Drehleiter,
Handschiebleiter.
Aber die kommen immer selber runter.
Ich musste noch nie
eine Katze herunterholen.
Die kommen hoch
und auch wieder runter.
Wieso geht ihr?
Ihr könntet sagen: "Wissen Sie ..."
Ich sage es, wie es ist:
Sie begreifen es manchmal nicht.
Katzen kommen runter -
wenn sie die Schnauze voll haben,
sie hungrig sind, ihnen kalt ist.
Oder hast du schon ein Katzenske-
lett auf einem Baum gesehen? Kaum.
Ja, du, und jetzt liegt der dort
und hält Siesta.
(Im Schnitt rücken die Feuer-
wehrmänner siebenmal pro Tag aus.)
(Dass es wirklich brennt, ist sel-
ten, erfahre ich auf dem Rückweg.)
Manchmal sind wir einfach
das Sorgentelefon.
Da rufen Personen an,
die plaudern wollen.
Gewisse sagen: "Wir sind
eine Einsatzzentrale. Wiederhören."
Denn du merkst,
die wollen einfach reden.
Ich bin immer der, der sagt:
"Ja, erzählen Sie mal."
Ich sage ihnen ganz klar:
"Wenn ein Notruf reinkommt,
lege ich grusslos auf."
Wahrscheinlich werde ich mit den
Jahren auch sagen: "Sorry, aber ..."
Du redest wirklich mit ihnen?
- Ja.
Und hörst ab,
was sie dir erzählen wollen.
Ja, ich war mal mit einer,
es war 22 Uhr,
eine Dreiviertelstunde am Telefon.
Aber eben,
ich habe ihr ganz klar gesagt:
"Wenn ein Notruf reinkommt,
lege ich auf, ohne ..."
Die Dargebotene Feuerwehr.
Ja, wir sind
für alles zu haben - fast alles.
(Es ist Mittag. Und der einzige
Einsatz läuft ... in der Küche.)
Kann man essen?
- Ja.
Was ist los?
- (Thomi) Du kannst helfen.
Kochen können, gehört das auch
zu euren Qualifikationen?
Zu den Qualifikationen nicht, aber
es sind viele verlorene Köche hier.
Sicher?
- Ja, ja.
Ihr kocht immer selber?
- Ja, genau.
Das Ziel sind immer 60 Sek.
Auch wenn du beim Kochen bist -
innert 60 Sek. ausrücken.
Pfanne weg, dann gehen wir.
Dort sind zwei grosse rote Knöpfe.
Wo?
- Da.
Not-Aus für den Herd.
Du haust drauf, Kochherd, Backofen,
dann ist hier alles tot.
(Es gibt Älplermagronen.)
(Alle) Guten Appetit.
Sie sind sehr gut. Darf ich euch
beiden ein Kompliment machen?
Beiden.
(Aber nach dem Storcheneinsatz
war auch das Kochen für die Katz.)
* Viermaliger Gong *
(Alarm.)
(Dieses Mal geht es nicht um einen
mutmasslich verletzten Storch.)
Eine Türöffnung.
Da ist eine Person in einem Raum,
die nicht reagiert.
Okay.
Das ist jetzt ernsthaft.
- Ja, das merke ich.
Wohin?
- Untere Rebgasse, Migros.
Person hinter einer Türe.
Reagiert nicht.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
* Sirene *
Ist die Sanität auch bereits da?
- Sie ist gerade vorgefahren.
Die ist schon oben? Euer Job ist,
die Türe aufzubrechen?
Wir müssen schauen,
wie wir das jetzt machen.
* Leises Stimmengewirr *
Sälü. Wir sollten rein, der Patient
liegt direkt neben der Türe.
* Händetrockner,
unverständliches Gespräch *
... die Leiter.
Die Beine, dann herum.
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
(Hinter der Türe
finden wir einen Mann
mit einem
Herz-Kreislauf-Stillstand.)
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
(Während 12 Min.
versuchen die Sanitäter und Patrick,
den Mann wiederzubeleben.)
(Leider ohne Erfolg.)
(Sanitäter) Dann lassen wir
alles so. Die Pads lassen wir dran.
Können wir euch jetzt
noch bei etwas helfen?
Ist gut?
Manchmal kann man helfen,
man hat Erfolg.
Und manchmal
spielt einfach die Zeit gegen einen,
oder was auch immer,
je nach Einstellung,
ist der Lebensfaden fertiggesponnen
oder eine höhere Macht, die sagt:
"Jetzt ist fertig."
Dann nützt halt alles nichts mehr.
- Ja.
Genau, so ist das.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wie ist es für dich?
Mir ist es ziemlich eingefahren.
Ja, weisst du, wie ...
Ich glaube,
das ist einfach so,
wenn du
einen Menschen dort liegen siehst.
Du weisst ja nicht,
wie sein Leben war,
aber dass ein Leben
in einem WC zu Ende geht,
wünscht man niemandem.
Nein, das ist kein so toller Ort,
nein.
* Sanfte Klavier-
und Streicherklänge *
(Woran der Mann gestorben ist,
erfahren wir nicht.)
(Die Feuerwehr
ist nur für die Türöffnung
und Unterstützung
bei Erster Hilfe zuständig.)
Wir sind wieder zurück.
- Ja, danke.
Das war ein heftiger Einstieg
für dich.
Ja.
Das ist unser Leben.
Es ist ein Gehen und ein Kommen.
Das ist das Tragische.
Wie soll ich sagen?
Ich hatte meinen ersten Todesfall
nach 14 Tagen.
Jemand, der im Auto verbrannte.
Man muss eine gewisse Distanz
dazu bekommen.
Man muss eine Mauer aufbauen,
damit es nur bis hierher kommt.
Und hier ist unser geschützter
Rahmen. Sonst gehst du kaputt.
Aber wenn man eine Mauer aufbaut -
besteht nicht die Gefahr,
ein kaltschnäuziger, zynischer Kerl
zu werden?
Vielleicht von aussen.
Aber es nimmt jeden mit.
Ich kann dir alle nennen,
die ich hatte,
die gestorben sind.
Es war so und so, war an jenem Ort
bei einem Brand ...
25 Jahre später kannst du sagen:
"Dort war er, so passierte es."
Aber ...
Wie soll ich sagen? Du darfst
es nicht viel näher ranlassen.
Wenn du es immer nach Hause nimmst,
gehst du plötzlich kaputt.
(Patrick) Du musst schauen,
ob es heiss ist.
Ja, es ist ziemlich heiss.
Es ist auch aufgewärmt tipptopp.
Da kann man nichts sagen.
Nach dem dritten, vierten Mal
wird es langsam hart.
(Nach dem Mittagessen
gehe ich zur Schlauchwäscherei.)
(Jeder Feuerwehrmann
hat sein Ämtchen.)
(Chris ist verantwortlich
für die Schlauchwartung.)
Es gleicht ein bisschen
einem Labyrinth.
* Dröhnen *
Das ist nicht das Monster,
das auf uns wartet.
(Die Schläuche
werden nicht nur gewaschen,
sondern auch geprüft.)
Hallo zusammen.
- Hallo zusammen.
Wir sind da.
Das grösste Waschbecken,
das ich je gesehen habe.
Man kann es
auch zur grössten Bar umbauen.
Im Normalfall,
wenn wir im Brandeinsatz sind,
geben wir 6-8 bar drauf.
Zum Prüfen geben wir 20 bar drauf.
- Okay.
Das ist die Druckerhöhungsanlage.
Wir drehen hier das Rädchen auf
und geben Druck drauf.
Jetzt gehen wir bis 20 bar.
Jetzt ist der geplatzt.
- Jetzt ist er ... Ja.
Schau dir das an!
Und diesen Test
macht ihr genau deshalb?
Um zu verhindern, dass einer platzt.
Ja, im Einsatz
darf das nicht passieren.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn ich mich
für euren Beruf entscheiden würde,
würde mich das hier
überhaupt nicht interessieren.
Dann würde ich
draussen Feuer löschen wollen.
Das ist bei mir auch so.
Das klingt jetzt krass,
aber am liebsten wäre ich 24 Std.
draussen, um meinen Job zu machen.
Denn das ist mein Beruf.
Ich mache das gerne.
Ich helfe den Menschen gerne.
Aber es ist ja dann nicht so toll
für die Menschen in Basel,
denn irgendjemand
hätte immer ein Problem,
wenn ich 24 Std. draussen wäre.
Aber grundsätzlich macht
das Ausrücken mehr Spass als das.
Gegen oben und nach hinten klappen.
Du kannst sie gegen ... Ja.
(Nur bei jedem achten Einsatz
muss die Feuerwehr
tatsächlich einen Brand bekämpfen.)
(Aber dann
muss jeder Handgriff sitzen.)
(Einmal pro Woche schult Chris die
Bevölkerung im Umgang mit Bränden.)
(Und heute bin ich dran.)
Sumi hat etwas vorbereitet.
Es brennt.
Womit löschst du normalerweise?
- Mit Wasser.
(Ausser es ist Öl.)
What the fuck!
Wir fangen unten an. Direkt.
Genau.
Das ist der Super-GAU,
wenn du Wasser zu Öl giesst.
Aber das weiss man ja eigentlich.
Nicht?
Man staunt,
wie wenige Menschen das wissen.
Auch oben beim Theorieteil:
"Ja, ich weiss es! Wasser."
So was von falsch. Dann bist du
Geschichte. Das überlebst du nicht.
Wirklich? - Es gibt eine riesige
Stichflamme. Du erschreckst dich.
Du atmest die Flammen
und die giftigen Gase ein,
das verbrennt innerlich alles.
Das ist ...
... saugefährlich.
(Und dann erfahre ich auch noch,
dass es lebensgefährlich sein kann,
wenn man zu ordentlich ist.)
Wenn der Keller brennt
und dort grosse Gasflaschen stehen -
die Hütte ist weg.
Ich habe sie wirklich im Keller.
Ich schäme mich gerade.
Aber das verstaut man doch
im Keller, das macht doch jeder.
Man lässt das Gaszeug
doch nicht draussen.
Den Grill
lässt du auch draussen, oder?
Äh, ja, stimmt. Also gut.
- Eine Plane drüber und gut ist.
(Zur Demonstration zündet Patrick
nur die kleine Gaskartusche an.)
(Chris) Irgendwann wird der Boden
angehoben. Das ist jetzt passiert.
Eigentlich sollte sie dann
wegrollen. Das passiert hier nicht.
Wahnsinn!
Hast du gespürt,
wie die Türe gekommen ist? - Ja.
Das waren 190 g.
Das war die kleine. Stell dir
die Explosion der grossen vor.
Das wären 10,5 kg.
* Jazzige Klänge *
Innere Margarethen,
120, 458, Kriterium 1.
(Patrick) Habe ich.
- Innere Margarethen 5.
Achtung,
erster Löschzug Tuss.
Die Jacke, die Jacke!
- Jesses Gott!
(Ein Brandmelder in einem Geschäfts-
haus hat einen Alarm ausgelöst.)
* Sirene *
(Während der Fahrt
erzählen meine Kameraden,
dass sie diese Woche schon dreimal
dorthin ausgerückt sind.)
(Gebrannt hat es nie.)
(Dreimal haben Bauarbeiten im Haus
den Alarm ausgelöst.)
(Und jetzt also Einsatz Nummer 4.)
* Piependes Alarmsignal *
Stammkunde.
Wir gehen ein paar Schritte.
- Wir müssen wirklich nachschauen?
Darf man nicht den Lift nehmen?
Nein, sieben Stockwerke zu Fuss.
(Beim x-ten Alarm würde ich es
schon ein bisschen lockerer nehmen.)
(Und wäre genau deshalb
am falschen Ort bei der Feuerwehr.)
Oh, das geht in die Waden.
("Wenn sich der Schlendrian
einschleicht,
wird es lebensgefährlich,
falls es dann doch brennt",
sagt Einsatzleiter Thomi.)
(Thomi) Achtung, Kopf.
Der müsste rot leuchten?
- Ja.
Ja.
Doch, schau, hier ist er.
Wir haben ihn gefunden, zuoberst.
Lüftungsmelder. Zurückschalten.
(Auch heute haben Bauarbeiten
den Brandmelder ausgelöst.)
Unten entsteht Staub.
Der wird von der Lüftung angesogen.
Der Staub kommt hier rein.
Der hier sagt: "Hey, stopp!"
"Hier brennt es."
Dann schlägt er Alarm.
Ja. Aber das ist
einfach schlecht eingestellt.
Wenn ihr jedes Mal kommen müsst,
obwohl nichts ist.
Nicht schlecht eingestellt,
vielmehr müsste diese Anlage
abgemeldet sein.
"Wir führen Bauarbeiten durch
von 7-17 Uhr."
Dann können wir sie abschalten.
Dann würde er auch nicht losgehen.
Sobald die Bauarbeiten beendet sind:
"Bitte Gebäude wieder schützen."
Es kostet jedes Mal.
Was kostet es, wenn wir
mit zwei Fahrzeugen ausrücken?
Das kostet 1'500 Fr.
plus Mehrwertsteuer.
Ein ...
Ein ziemlicher Batzen. Pro Einsatz.
Genau. Gehen wir wieder runter!
- Sieben Stockwerke.
Hu! Mannschaft: Jacke ausziehen!
Achtung, Kopf.
(Für den vierten Einsatz
in der gleichen Woche
muss der Hauseigentümer
6'000 Fr. hinblättern.)
(Plus Mehrwertsteuer.)
(Zum Abendessen
gibt es doch noch ein Feuer.)
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
Wieso sind hier nur Männer?
Ich bin die einzige Frau, oder?
Nächstes Jahr gibt es eine
Bewerbung. Bist du älter als 35?
Leider ja. Ein bisschen.
Zwei, drei Monate.
Nein, Frauen ... Es ist halt ...
Ich glaube nicht, dass es daran
liegt, dass viele Männer da sind.
Wenn wir fünf bis acht Frauen
gleichzeitig einstellen würden,
könnte man sich
auch etwas austauschen
und sich unter Gleichgesinnten
aufhalten.
Bisher hatten wir immer
eine bis zwei Frauen.
Dann haben sie sich
wieder neu orientiert.
So.
(Vor sieben Jahren
hörte die letzte Frau auf.)
(Seither ist die Berufsfeuerwehr
wieder eine reine Männer-WG.)
* Sanfte pulsierende Klänge *
* Gläserne Klänge *
(Meine Kollegen entspannen sich.)
(Aber mich plagt
vor der Nachtruhe die Angst,
dass ich es nicht innert 60 Sek.
in den Einsatz schaffe.)
(Deshalb
habe ich Vorkehrungen getroffen.)
Best Pyjama in the world.
Wer braucht einen Schlafsack, wenn
er in dieser Hose schlafen kann?
Ihr weckt mich, falls ich
nicht aufwachen sollte, oder?
* Ein Telefon klingelt. *
Feuerwehr-Notruf.
Und wie sieht dieser Rauch aus?
Wir kommen sofort, jawohl.
Gut, auf Wiederhören.
Achtung, erster Löschzug Gross,
Rauch,
Einstellhalle Aescherstrasse 14.
(Chris) Wir gehen! Wir gehen!
* Klopfen *
Komme!
* Viermaliger Gong *
Schuhe? Die habe ich unten.
(Lautsprecher) Achtung,
erster Löschzug Gross ...
Aescherstrasse 14.
Vielen Dank.
(Vor 60 Sek. schlief ich noch.)
(Jetzt sind wir auf dem Weg
zu einem mutmasslichen Hausbrand,
der von Nachbarn gemeldet wurde.)
* Sirene *
(Ein leichter Rauchgeruch
hängt in der Luft.)
(Die Bewohner dieses Hauses
sind im Urlaub,
erfahren wir von den Nachbarn.)
Jetzt sind sie dort oben.
Sie sehen sich um.
* Sie lachen. *
Sie haben sich überall umgesehen.
Auch hinter dem Haus.
Man riecht es,
da kommt ein Wölkchen.
Es ist ein Piepen.
Das ist ein privater Brandmelder,
der losgegangen ist.
Aber sie wissen nicht genau, wo.
Sie suchen ihn.
Der Geruch deutet darauf hin,
dass etwas ...
Irgendetwas war.
Aber es kann irgendwoher kommen.
Je nachdem, wie der Wind steht.
Je nachdem war es jemand,
der im Hinterhof grillierte.
Oder ein Holzfeuer hatte,
das er löschte.
Dass da noch eine letzte Wolke ...
Hier etwas auslöste.
Genau. Oder es kann
von irgendwoher kommen.
(Nach einigen Minuten finden wir
tatsächlich zwei Anwohner,
die ein Feuer gemacht hatten.)
Auf dem Balkon.
- Auf der Dachterrasse.
Wir haben es wirklich jetzt erst
gecheckt, als ihr gekommen seid.
Wirklich ... Wir hörten oben Musik.
Waren schon halb eingeschlafen.
Thomi, bei mir sind zwei Personen,
die auf ihrem Balkon
eine Feuerschale angezündet hatten.
(In der Zwischenzeit hat Thomi
den Brandmelder entdeckt
und zurückgestellt.)
(Auch das war also
ein sog. Täuschungsalarm.)
Ein bisschen müde. Ehrlich gesagt.
- Du hast aber nicht geschlafen?
Fast. Ich bin die Einzige hier drin,
die schon ein bisschen ...
Nicht?
(Kaum eingedöst,
geht es wieder los.)
* Heulender Alarm *
(Lautsprecher) Grossalarm,
erster Löschzug. Museum Tinguely.
* Klopfen *
Komme!
(Diesmal bin ich so schnell,
dass ich schon aus dem Zimmer bin,
als das Licht angeht.)
(Wieder ging ein Brandmelder los.)
(Diesmal an einem
besonderes delikaten Ort.)
* Sirene *
(Kurz nach Mitternacht
landen wir im Tinguely-Museum.)
(Der Brandmelder in einem
Maschinenraum im Untergeschoss
hat Alarm ausgelöst.)
Wenn du hier reinschaust,
haben wir da etwas Rauch.
Hier ist der Kompressorraum.
Hier?
- Genau.
Schau hier.
Hier siehst du ...
Der leuchtet.
Hier haben wir Öl.
Warte kurz!
Das Problem war,
dass er wahrscheinlich überhitzte.
Dadurch entwickelte sich Dampf,
also Rauch.
So wurde der Brandmelder ausgelöst.
Ein technischer Defekt.
Wieso rückt man da
sofort mit allen Wagen aus?
Wäre es nicht besser, jemanden
zu schicken, der sich das ansieht,
um Geld zu sparen,
falls es nichts ist?
Die Frage ist, wo wir Geld sparen,
wenn wir mit einem Wagen ausrücken,
z.B. mit Drehleiter.
Wenn etwas ist im Museum Tinguely,
mit seinen Wertgegenständen -
die Frage ist, wo man Geld spart,
wenn etwas ist.
Es dauert 5 Min., bis wir hier sind.
6, 7 Min.
Wenn es brennt,
sind 6-7 Min. eine lange Zeit.
Ja.
* Entspannte jazzige Klänge *
(Gute Nacht zum Dritten.)
Der Trick ist einfach:
nicht unter der Decke liegen,
sondern drauf.
Denn die Hosen wärmen so sehr. Das
würde man sonst gar nicht aushalten.
Gute Nacht.
(Von 2-6 Uhr morgens ging tat-
sächlich kein Brandmelder mehr los
in der Stadt Basel.)
Ich habe es geschafft.
- Ja, es war cool.
Und ihr wisst schon, weshalb.
- Ja, ja.
Das ist wie ein Schlafsack.
Du liegst in dieser Riesenhose.
Es ist wie ein Schlafsack,
aus dem du nie raus musst,
mit dem du sogar
gut die Stange runterkommst.
Du verbrennst dir nichts. Nicht wie
wir. - Ich kann's empfehlen.
Auch wenn du
etwas skeptisch schaust.
Es ist ein bisschen warm für uns.
Wenn du weisst, was die alles mit-
machen, schläfst du nicht mehr drin.
Du meinst, du bist manchmal froh,
wenn du aus dieser Hose rauskommst?
Wie eine Hülle, die du
abstreifen kannst. - Das stimmt.
Die Arbeit ablegen. Einige tun das.
Ich mache das.
- Wirklich?
Man sagt: "Ich habe Feierabend."
Und mit der Arbeitskleidung legt man
die ganze Arbeit ab und geht ...
Nach Hause.
- In einen neuen Tag.
Ja, und in ein privates Leben.
(Beide) Genau.
Wie weit in die Höhe geht der?
- 45 m.
45?
Ja, gut. Also.
Also. Auch das
werden wir noch überstehen.
Genau.
(Vor dem Schichtwechsel um 7 Uhr
zeigen mir Thomi und seine Jungs
noch ihr spektakulärstes
Einsatzfahrzeug: den Hebekran.)
Hey, wow! Das ist Wahnsinn.
Das ist doch cool.
(Meine Schicht bei der
Berufsfeuerwehr Basel geht zu Ende.)
(Patrick, Thomi und Chris
haben 24 Std. frei,
bis sie wieder einrücken.
Allzeit bereit.)
(Denn auch nach
dem x-ten Täuschungsalarm
tritt irgendwann wieder
der Ernstfall ein.)
* Entspannte Streicherklänge *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2019